what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
yada yada yada blah blah blah so on and
so forth intro statement Adam warlock
all right let's do this let's have this
conversation there are a couple things
we need to go over first though the
first is that I don't have any Adam
warlock comics so I apologize that I can
upload any I guess maybe comic book
panels for you guys to look at while
you're watching this video so maybe you
can surf the web or something like that
but again I do apologize for that I
always try to keep something interesting
in the background while you guys watch
these videos the other thing is I know I
haven't uploaded a video for the last
few days but my Russian 91% came in and
those of you guys who know anything
about vaping know that the Russian 91%
is a big deal I've been waiting months
and months and months to try to find one
because everywhere sold out I finally
found one at vapor shark ordered it it
came in built the coil a few times they
were to get used to it and I'm vaping it
right now and I'm actually vaping
unicorn poop from the vapor chef which
is amazing so anyway let's get into this
video Adam warlock is a really
interesting character in Marvel Comics
because Adam warlock is a guy who
doesn't appear very often he's a lot
like dr. strange he doesn't show up all
the time but when he does show up you
know that some really really big things
are going to happen Adam warlock is not
a mutant and he is not a human being
he's actually an artificially created
person and he was created by a extremely
radical group called The Enclave these
were a crazy group of scientists that
wanted to create a dictatorial society
on the planet Earth and they needed
someone that could pave the way and
eliminate all opposition so that they
could achieve their goal now even in
1967 when Adam Adam warlock is first
introduced to us during a couple issues
actually of the Fantastic Four you still
had a reasonably diverse and powerful
Marvel Universe of course it's nothing
like it is now in 2014 but even in 1967
you still had some variant of the x-men
you had the Fantastic Four you had the
Avengers and you even had criminals
Doctor Doom and Red Skull people like
that who were kind of prominent members
in the Marvel Universe and the villains
have their own goals they wanted to
achieve and of course the heroes wanted
to keep something like this from
happening and so there was still a
reasonable case for The Enclave to make
to say we need someone powerful enough
to keep all these people out of the way
while we engage in this effort to create
a
hater ship on the planet Earth and so
they created Adam warlock now initially
Adam warlock didn't have a name he was
simply just referred to as him and he
existed in this kind of cocoon so to
speak and the cocoon that he uses is
designed to I guess reinvigorate himself
or simply a place for him to stay until
he is needed later on at some point in
time depending on the storyline of the
plot that Marvel writes out suffice it
to say the Fantastic Four come into
conflict with the Enclave and the
attempt of the Enclave to create a
dictatorship and of course they
successfully thwart the Enclave with the
assistance of Adam warlock who turns
against the Enclave almost as soon as he
is released from there he takes off the
parts of space unknown and we don't
really hear from him again
until I don't know maybe 1972 or
something like that and at the time Adam
warlock was being rewritten because it
was kind of this shuffling that was
going on with regards to the riders over
in Marvel Comics and I think Roy Thomas
was the guy who took over for writing
Adam warlock and he was a huge fan of
the Jesus Christ Superstar musical and
so he wanted to rewrite Adam warlock in
a way that Adam warlock kind of came
across as a christ-like person now this
doesn't mean that Adam warlock was
crucified and then he died and then came
back to life three days later and he's
not an exact parallel to Jesus Christ so
much more than he is a character that
people usually rally around he's kind of
this great big huge leader and he's kind
of viewed as a deity in the sense that
he can die with it he's resurrected or
different things like that but we're not
going to go into the whole religious
concept of the religious comparison
between Adam warlock and Jesus Christ
suffice it to say there comes a point
when we come back into contact with Adam
warlock again and this is during the
counter-earth High Evolutionary kind of
storyline was going on and the High
Evolutionary was this guy who was able
to manipulate genetics he is probably
the most intelligent person with regards
to genetics in the Marvel Universe and
he created this sort of counter-earth I
guess is the best way to describe it it
is a variant of the earth on the other
side of the Sun and is almost exactly
like ours but there's one major
difference the High Evolutionary really
kind of specializes so to speak and
manipulating the genes of animals to
give them I guess maybe superpowers and
human being level intellect so imagine
imagine this imagine that the High
Evolutionary basically creates people or
creates characters like Rocket Raccoon
from guardians of the galaxy but the
difference is that these characters have
superpowers one of the characters that
he creates is a guy named man beast and
man beast was initially not supposed to
be as powerful as he is but the problem
was at the time that man beast is the
time that his jeans were being
manipulated by the High Evolutionary
Thor intervened and Thor intervened
because the High Evolutionary had
kidnapped Jane Foster for the purpose of
having her effectively teach these
creatures what they needed to know in
order to be intelligent in order to be
able to function outside of the most
basic primitive instincts that they had
that they had retained since they were
still for the most part animals as Thor
and the High Evolutionary are fighting
each other the genes of the man beast
continues to be they continue to evolve
they continue to be manipulated and the
problem is that by the time it's all
stopped by the time he is I guess taken
away from this gene this gene
accelerator I think is what it is
he has evolved to a virtually
super-powerful character he has
telepathy and telekinesis and he can
create force fields and he can take over
the mind of other people and he has
enhanced senses and he can manipulate
all kinds of physical and exotic
energies and it's really kind of crazy
all the powers that he has but he is a
formidable character for anyone to go
against and so the High Evolutionary
prematurely wakes up Adam warlock and
this is very important because Adam
warlock prior to being woken up
prematurely by the High Evolutionary had
your normal run-of-the-mill super powers
that is to say enhanced strength enhance
speed stamina durability so on and so
forth but he also had the ability to
manipulate large amounts of the power
cosmic but the problem was because of
the fact that he was woken up
prematurely his ability to manipulate
vast amounts of the power cosmic went
away
and so now he has a far more reduced
ability to manipulate the power cosmic
although he is still a very formidable
character to go against when the High
Evolutionary wakes up Adam warlock he
informs that a Morlock of the situation
enlist his aid in defeating man beast
and restoring order to counter earth and
also gives Adam warlock a soldier where
he gives them these soul Jim one of
these six infinity gems
now this is extremely important in the
life of Adam warlock and the reason why
is because we see a future version of
Adam warlock called the Magus and this
is a possible future version of Adam
warlock where he has gone insane due to
his use of the soul gym in addition to
some manipulation by the in-betweener
now the character The Magus play some
pretty pivotal roles and stories like
the the Thanos imperative and he plays a
pretty important role just in the
overall viewpoint of Adam warlock and
his perception of his future now what
Adam warlock actually ends up doing with
regards to the Magus is he travels into
the future and takes the soul gem away I
think or something along those lines and
basically keeps his future self from
becoming the maggots but nonetheless of
course Adam warlock is successful in
defeating man beast along with the
assistance of the High Evolutionary and
he really kind of goes back into hiding
again now throughout the different
journeys that Adam warlock gets involved
in he picks up different sidekicks one
of which of course is good more from the
guardians of the galaxy storyline the
other one is Pip and I don't remember if
he's like a goblin but he's a
weird-looking kind of creature but he's
also an assistant to Adam warlock and
the three of them really kind of get
into a lot of different adventures now
eventually there comes a point in time
where we come across the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline and at this point in
time Adam warlock pip and Gamora
actually reside within the soul gem
itself in this kind of perfect utopian
sort of world and it's actually the
Silver Surfer that alerts Adam warlock
to what's going on and please without a
Morlock to leave the soul Jim along with
Gamora and pip in order to help him
fight off Thanos or at the very least
try to hold them off long enough to
where they can get involved in the
effort to defeat Thanos and remove the
Infinity Gauntlet from his possession
and that's we're gonna stop the
discussion about the Infinity Gauntlet I
know some of you guys are probably
wondering are we gonna get into the
Infinity Gauntlet are we gonna finally
talk about the Infinity Gauntlet I
promise you guys that discussion is
coming but we got to iron out some stuff
we got to talk about some stuff for us
we can't just just you know start going
into the Infinity Gauntlet you got to
pre-heat the oven before you stick in
the turkey as Michelle said from
American Pie you know you gotta you
gotta prep the stove you know you got to
get the ingredients to
you got to get the pot brewing and then
you can start to season and then we can
have a discussion about the Infinity
Gauntlet I love food I'm a huge fan of
food so anyway we're going to go and
bring this video to an end by the way
actually before we do I have a question
for any of you guys I'm posting the
comments if you know and no cheating you
can't google the answer to this although
you probably will which of you guys know
whether or not Adam warlock was in Thor
to the dark world if you did just say
like I did and say where say where you
saw him like send me a message that's
the best way to do send me a message and
let me know because I'm curious because
if you guys didn't we'll have a
discussion on that anyway uh yeah we're
going to bring this video to an end and
I will catch you guys later peace